peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'est-ce qu'elle vire tous ses
charmes au t3 très très bien comment
fait on souffre la cie la musique bien
par ici
oh et ça va pas j'appuie sur le piston
la musique ne ferai pas
j'entends la faire
madame retarder la mise
via paris
quel sens va pas
non
d
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
baudis homme moi madame si mon
instrument goût chloré
j'avoue jours et la gamme le plaisir
sera complet
oh
[Musique]
dit accompagnerez mais oui mais oui mais
oui ou non nous sommes seuls madame je
ne jouerai plus que beaucoup
où
oui
les autres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais soit
madame au bistrot des voix
mais
[Musique]
et
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour être heureux
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour faire la
fête
y'a les violettes tendon envie de
galérer
[Musique]
sa peau
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour être heureux
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour perdre la
tête
la voûte et prêtre le chez les bleus
ya des chansons dans le piano il ya de
l'espoir au fond des yeux
et des sourires dans chaque faux c'est
de la mort nous guette c'est merveilleux
qu'est-ce qu'on a pas à l'étroit
jonathan
rien que ça
[Musique]
chantal
on
ils seront là tant qu'on l'attend
et on attend
et
[Musique]
bonjour docteur bon joueur que tu ne
m'as pas j'ai les faits sont dans
l'estomac
oui j'ai fait de rire quand qu'il faut
pas y chez les capitals l'opéra où
sortez-vous keystone la fnaca du doigt
oui oui vous tapez luchini oui
complètement chabal a pris 4
oui si le contingent composé par us
au secondaire c'est un gros chewing gums
hubert trac mais quand il est là il
voyous vacances oui complètement chauve
souris
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur le curé je voudrais
bien me confesser à qui la salle
le champion jazz tous les cantons
c'est formidable
[Musique]
oui ça d'esprit chabada ce we can diane
taille
[Musique]
c'est déjà ça
charles oui
[Musique]
oh
ce matin
[Applaudissements]
et rés
l'elysée et la vie est facile d
j'adore
les poissons
sauf nous
il
et le coton
auj
votre papa
richir
yom en chine
et votre maman elle regarde bien
[Musique]
les uv
jung kwan
aussi chute petit bébé
pleurs
là
un de ces quatre mots
c
vous allez vous masser
en chantant des lyonnais
[Musique]
vous allez
temps pour bosser
d'où des scans et monter jusqu'au ciel
bâtir au
mais jusqu'à ce matin
[Musique]
il y a
bottes arriver
rien
m
tél
papa et maman à côté
[Musique]
c'est dur
quand tu m'as quitté
je n'ai pas très bien compris
j'étais propos recueil eux
outre au sol peut être je ne sais plus
quel gâchis pourquoi
faron
[Musique]
c'est l'été
non
et tu m'as quitté
[Musique]
man est un des stades
l envie vous iloveyou pas
ça me va
[Musique]
oh
et
[Musique]
matin vous ouvrez la fenêtre l'air vous
semble soudain plus léger c'est comme un
frisson kim open line pro vie qui est
quelque chose de changé
tiens tiens tiens déjà les feuilles vous
ce jack 1 500 le romarin dans les
jardins les lilas se trémousse et les
petites femmes ont déjà les pépins tiens
quelqu'un les chiens lève la fatwa le 4
5 1 les vents vont les bambins on va
déjà pour les chais pour les chats et
les esclaves aux galopeurs avant que
nous
la vie nous saurons rien
il se passe quelque chose tiens tiens
tiens on joue de la mandoline chacun 400
qui leur offre un gala des changements
sur les lèvres des copines et des petits
boutons sur le déni comme un cache de
moi dans le monde des gamins les charges
y aurait des débutants et tous les
faveurs du poil dans la main
[Musique]
m
toutes les
summer
s'il faut bien que keyes semences
tiens tiens tiens là qu'était le
transport de 4 kg 1 joe schreiber
soudain que l'on frappe à ma porte
il je reconnais la balle que j'aime bien
kkp ya deux ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'est ce qui est arrivé est
arrivé à bout
un beau matin juillet le réveil a sonné
les lever du soleil
et j'ai dit à ma poupée pourtant secoué
c'est aujourd'hui tu prends
on arrive sur le boulevard sans retard
pour voir défiler le roi de zanzibar
sur le champ on est refoulé par les
agents alors j'ai on n'est pas là pour
se faire engueuler on est là pour voir
le défilé on est
moi là pour sa verte et il est en est
pour voir le défilé si vous le monde
était resté chez soi ça ferait du tort à
la rue
laissez nous donc on le regarde
sinon plus tard
reviendra manar
on est là
le journal fait injure mon poto jeux léa
un petit bistrot où l'on goûte un
beaujolais vrai de vrai un hectare de
on est sorti très à l'aise mais voilà
j'ai eu l'idée de ramener chez moi
j'ai compris
devant à l'euro
une saillie sur la tête
on est moi pour ce merveilleux et on est
là
on n'est pas là pour se faire assommer
on
si tout le monde reste m
ça serait triste et incroyable pour
cette forte sans les frais
nuts team fra aus en salle proche un
coup la marge en apprendre plus du tout
ma femme a cogné si forte
conte après passé le soir même eh ouais
11h30 annie arménie
il y avait quelques élus tirent en prêt
c'est toujours un point jugé
la foule
semaine
en danger
on n'est pas là pour se faire engueuler
je vais essayer
au rayon
m
concernant les taux
bravo restait beaucoup de
portez vous
ou pas
alors on est plus en plus chez satan et
en france et n est pas tant ces
mouvements proches
paris l'état
n'est pas
denis
m
non
[Musique]
les loges et vieux ventilateur essayait
de brasser les cours d'eau leur aurait
pu palper a peur dans une aussi épaisse
moite
pour la douzième fois de la soirée
jamais frappé les rangs merdé troisième
bouton de son billet pour toi maso
vraiment
[Musique]
à la grande table se moquer d'eux a
planqué sous la théière le vicomte
lancer les enchères une main posée sur
revolver
[Musique]
les normes et vieux ventilateur mélanger
friture espace on sentait monter la
terreur comme s'il y avait plus besoin
très vite rouler sur ces bancs gros pour
avoir sifflé trou de coco regarder
partir samad au ras des gigantesques
travaux
[Musique]
et sous la le coup de feu le vicomte
morfle entre les deux yeux pour une fois
qu'ils avaient lu je rigole max en
rangeant son faux
[Musique]
macao matin
à
oh
ans
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis sa boucle struzan une oui oui
oui j'habite dans les rues la soirée
[Musique]
je vois j
j'y vois partout sur les cuisses
je vous déteste et je veux mourir genest
complet oui
un gosse genac
quand jacques
chaud
rien ne va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
non
[Musique]
eba
allez
ce qu'ils ont
oui
car elle
gfr
je l'étais coach qui est jeune et
fouette gèle tout prix
bref sous les chênes
[Musique]
pourchassant les oublie le démon du site
là mais depuis samedi matin
aujourd'hui
ça
élément sa femme
d
[Musique]
m
oui l'arrière
jeudi
[Musique]
penalty
je paye
[Musique]
des pensions pour fait cuire les pommes
pipi carpet
[Musique]
ça c'est bon
sa femme
mais bon
ça
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
raddad
[Musique]
on s'amuse comme des fous
lisbonne au message au micro je rigole
les fous on n'a pas
[Musique]
j
à super musique à ses 3
[Musique]
je ne sais je sais moi pour cole
jouera-t-il
pas les vallées
yara de pirates
[Musique]
oui
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cours
[Musique]
un coup de vent des abeilles est envahi
la gaule
il ne reste qu'un seul virage qui ne
peut plus pâle esclavage
[Musique]
mais assez
c'est une bande dessinée vendue dans le
monde entier mais qu'est ce qu'ils
disent est abruti il faut le livre est à
césar qui le traitera dans la poule est
bien attaché à son choix
[Musique]
m
assez vite
à vos derniers rangs mon petit mot cours
paul propre tout sauf en gymnastique
je vous ai code promo astérix était plus
forte que tous les plus gros malabar
le couple est gros et les autres auront
mêmes conan le barbare
pas mal du tout mademoiselle prévoit dix
premières en éducation sexuelle
alors quand je lis astérix à quoi
pensez-vous
attention ces familles réjouissent de
petits droit qui sert ne rend pas dans
la marque utilisée pour expliquer à un
détaillant
manche lui l'art chewing vous aurez vous
était tout nu dans l'arène parler car
c'est de leur enfant
[Musique]
pour vous
à savoir
[Musique]
inona no mistake
ravi en rien stoppé au pire de boulettes
ou réfectoire du lycée good times
l'élu estime sa peluche le lancet les
romains dans les herbes giro-tour belle
va mettre derrière la tête enfoncée dans
la terre va pour mes parents
mademoiselle hirschau même pas française
est la vie qui est le vôtre
il existe un héros comme inspirée
[Musique]
qu'elle raconte
c'est lamentable vous serez limité à la
tribu belge il dit côté surintendant
d'autres guerres tout seul à rouler dans
les prix
[Musique]
attention
pourquoi
je reprends ton pass tennis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]